I'm gonna be presenting lots of
different work from uh certain people
and a bunch of it is created by my team
on the other side of the bridge I work
with about sixty scientists from a bunch
of different places in many different
countries and so a lot of the work that
I'll be sharing that's from vicarious
itself is theirs and we're we're lucky
to be funded by some of my personal
heroes we've raised a little over 120
million dollars from people like Bezos
and Zuckerberg and Elon so on and we're
actually advised by one of one of
Stanford's in faith de leeuw is is one
of our advisors so we have a a gender
today talked about a couple different
things one is about the strengths and
limitations of modern AI systems and
I'll try and frame it in a way that's
acceptable to people who know a lot
about it and also understandable to
people who know a little bit about it so
I'm going to try and walk a very fine
line and then I'll run through some of
the different economic social and policy
implications that I expect this to have
in the near term and then this in future
and then finally I'd like to give at
least my set of predictions from where I
sit in the industry about what I expect
to be coming on the horizon so I think
there's this really interesting
relationship or lens we can have on the
development of artificial intelligence
that kind of maps it to the evolution of
animal intelligence so if we go back 600
million years we get to the very first
intelligent animals things like
jellyfish flatworm sea sponges and then
as time passes the animals get more
complicated I would argue they don't get
any smarter
it's just deeper layers of very simple
heuristics very narrow kinds of
behaviors in the neuroscience world this
is called the old brain and it's built
on stimulus and response it's build an
instinct and then about 100 million
years ago or 200 million years later
yeah 100 million years ago we got a
completely different architecture for
intelligence that evolution figured out
called the neocortex the new brain it's
what gave us primates whales dolphins
and you and me and instead of being
built on top of stimulus and response
and instinct it's built on top of
reasoning about causality reasoning
about what if and why
and mental simulation imagination those
are the sort of the hallmarks of mammals
versus our older brain ancestors and the
argument all makes today is that deep
learning and you know largely the
current generation of AI systems that we
see the proliferation of are in the big
yellow box here they're they're largely
based on instinctual stimulus response
kinds of behaviors and I'll give you
some examples from the animal kingdom
and also from the computer kingdom so we
can compare and contrast so from it's
not to say that there's anything wrong
with the old brain like old brain
animals are really cool they can do all
kinds of stuff that can navigate
complicated environments that can
control their limbs you know they can
reproduce the old brain is really really
cool but it has some really important
limitations to keep in mind when we
think about how it maps to AI system so
specifically to make an old brain animal
you need a couple of hundred million
years worth of evolutionary training
data and when you finish you're a Volvo
process for that animal you're going to
get a system that has very low
generalization to new environments that
has very low ability to learn new skills
or adapt and most importantly what will
be produced is an animal that gives the
illusion of intelligence without
actually being smart so like it will
give you a perception that the animal is
doing a behavior that is what a human
might do in the same circumstance
without actually having any of the
reasoning the back set up but I'll give
you some examples of that so in a
nutshell when you look at the old brains
architecture you have a you know a sound
or a video or a picture signal that
comes into the system there's a bunch of
very narrow heuristics that are stored
in the animal's brain and then it and
then it takes some action form some
response and so here's some sort of fun
examples baby geese make this noise
let's see if you can hear it and
scientists figured out that mother geese
will actually love and care for anything
that makes that sound so you can take a
tape recorder that plays that noise and
put it inside of a taxidermy of a wolf
and the mother goose will love and care
for the wolf as if it's one of its own
children
and similarly baby ducks exhibit this
really cool behavior where they follow
their mom and a very orderly fashion and
so you know if you
what they're actually doing is not
flying their mom they're following the
first thing they saw when they were born
so if the these baby ducks are born they
see a dog they will follow the dog
everywhere as if it's their mom so it's
like a very specific very narrow
heuristic the system is using in order
to produce intelligent looking behavior
and the same thing is true frogs the
Frog will actually starve itself to
death in front of an iPhone because it's
just performing the action if you see
this pixel pattern you shoot the tongue
and these are the same kinds of
behaviors you'll see in old brain AI
systems you know deep learning is great
it can do lots of really cool looking
things I can play tarah games or go
games they can even recognize photos and
and control robots but it has the same
limitations as the old brain does so it
takes a lot of training data to make a
deep learning system work the resulting
model is not going to generalize well to
new environments or circumstances and
it's not going to understand cause and
effect or understand what it's doing or
why it's it's going to give you the
illusion of intelligence and it even has
the same architecture as our old brain
friends so I want to give you guys a
tutorial about why this is and just to
take a quick temperature so who here
feels like they could give a concise
explanation of how alphago works how
many people ok like maybe 10% of you
maybe less so ok so I'm gonna give you a
tutorial about how at the end of this to
be able to tell your friends how alphago
works in a way that is I think pretty
true it's not exactly how alphago works
because that would be much longer talk
but it's close enough that it may as
well be so let's say we're gonna build
an AI system for reading handwritten
digits like these step one in building a
system like this is to collect thousands
or millions of hand labelled human
labelled training examples so this is
six thousand examples of the number zero
this is six thousand examples the number
one of the number two and so on you
gather 60,000 labeled training examples
and you feed them to the system and you
win then when you show it a new image
like this basically what it's doing is
it compares this to every image it's
seen and it's training data set so you
know flip through all the ones the twos
the threes and so on and eventually gets
here and it's like wait a minute these
are really close matches so you know
voila it's a four and if you want to
take that system and scale
from recognizing digits recognizing
photos you again collect a very large
corpus of hand label images like for
example we've labeled this image corn
because somewhere in the image there's
corn and then instead of 60,000 training
examples you'd show it over a million
this is the image net training set
courtesy of Stanford and then at the end
of that process you could showed a new
image and it would say this matches what
I know about cars but if you showed a
picture like this one it'll say it's a
bedroom pillow instead because it
doesn't really learn anything about cars
it's just doing very dumb pattern
matching and similarly you know it may
recognize this is a Jaguar but a hand
drawing of the exact same image it's
gonna have no idea what that is and it
will also recognize images like this as
Jaguars because it's just doing sort of
basic pattern matching and similarly
it's important to realize it's not
actually learning anything about objects
it like doesn't know that there's a such
thing as an object
it's just matching patterns and it's
matching the patterns that sees in
photos all mixed together so like if I
keep the bus the train and the cat the
same in these pictures and I just
changed the background a deep learning
system will say that it's a nymph in
snowplow and a chihuahua
so it's it's a very very simple and kind
of narrow way of recognizing things but
it happens to work if you have a really
big data set in a lot of compute and
it's susceptible to the kinds of tax
maybe some of you seen before where
because it's doing a very narrow form of
pattern matching you can take an image
that it will recognize yes which cues
are geometric or are you looking at
color maps or that's so that's the funny
thing about learning is it's hard to
tell you get a big monolithic black box
out of it and there's some dark magic
you can do to kind of try and figure out
how it's coming to the inclusions it's
coming to but the the real answer is you
really have no idea what the weights
inside the network mean and it happens
to work some of the time it happens to
fail other percent of the time your
question multi little neural networks
there are certainly other ways of doing
pattern recognition
and receiving learning Italy decision
trees are right and we'll get there is
it yellow or it's a green or whatever
yeah so that's I think that's getting
closer to the second half of the talk
about where I think things are going
because right now when you when you read
about AI you're generally speaking and
reading about deep learning and you know
every every conference submission deep
learning is is basically if that's not
on the title somewhere or in the
abstract somewhere then you pay a
penalty in terms of the likelihood of
your paper being accepted
so it's also susceptible these attacks
where you know you you can take an image
that it will recognize as a bus with
high confidence you can perturb it very
slightly and that's just enough to cause
it to miss recognize it as a completely
different class and you can do this with
with any photo there's lots of different
ways of generating these adversarial
cases that fool deep learning and do not
fool humans just so you know drill home
the point that these systems are not
doing human-like reasoning about
anything they're just doing very narrow
sense of pattern recognition and at the
same time you can also generate
completely nonsense images that it will
recognize with very high confidence as
all kinds of things actually have a deep
learning app on my phone that I can take
some pictures of these in your head
right now see if you can classify the
photos that are in front of you exactly
I think that's a that's a side effect of
the generator rather than of the
technology itself so let's see what this
one has to say any guesses so all of
them have similar kinds of reactions so
you can generate a nonsense patterns
that fit into the manifold but the deep
learning system has been trained
recognized without actually being those
objects so this is not this is not a
deep learning as bad talk this is just
one of the characteristics of deep
learning and this is one of them so to
make a deep learning system work you
need lots of training data and the
resulting system is not guaranteed to
generalize particularly well to new
environments and it doesn't understand
what it's doing doesn't have a causal
model of its
sell for of the world that it can be
used to reason and so when you and I
watch this is a google deepmind's famous
Atari player that's using deep
reinforcement learning we watch the
system we say ok the Pat it's using the
paddle to hit the ball to get the hit
the bricks to get points which is not at
all what's happening inside the AI
system what's actually happening inside
the system is they just take three
frames or four frames of the game and
they paste them together into one image
so that they make a whole bunch of
copies of this and to give you a sense
of the amount of data here this is our
60,000 digits this is the million photos
and this is the 50 million Atari frames
this is trained on so they paste you
know these three frames or four frames
together and then they do that 50
million times and then after playing the
game at random to start with and playing
it more and more you eventually begin to
notice oh I went left and I lost points
so I'm going to classify that image or
that series images as a go right series
and images and then vice versa and then
over time you're able to to do pattern
recognition where when you see a series
of frames you classify it as whether you
should go left or go right and you can
tell that that's what the system is
doing because small changes break this
algorithm in the same ways that changes
break the other you know deep learning
systems we looked at so if you want to
for example change the rules of the game
slightly where the ball bounces higher
or the paddles bigger or it's in a
different position all of these things
you'll need to retrain your deep
learning system from scratch with
another 50 million frames of the game
and you can see it really very clearly
so I took that train model and just
increase the brightness of the game by 2
percent so increasing the brightness of
the game with 2 percent is enough to
cause it to do this instead of playing
the game and with alphago it's it's
almost the same story you take you know
an input go board and down here now is
our 60,000 digits this is our million
photos that's the 50 million Atari
frames and this is the billion go boards
that's required to Train alpha go to
play go and to put that in perspective
that's about three thousand years of a
human playing go for 24 hours a day 7
days a week without sleep and so it's a
it's a lot of training data and then
after those billion go boards are played
it gets and it tallies up the scores
every time it gets a sense of what are
the boards that look like losing boards
we're the ones look like winning boards
and so anytime it's
seeing a you know a new go board like
this one it can then search over all
possible descendant states of the board
and pick the ones that are the
winningest and voila you have alphago so
if you wanted to play a different game
like chess instead of go it's another
three thousand years of training
changing the rules slightly all the
things that humans adapt to really well
are things that the system is not going
to do you can also apply these same kind
of architectures to control robots this
is Google X's recent achievement called
the arm farm they wanted to have a
robotic system that could grasp objects
and to get these systems to grasp
objects that are all roughly the same
size
it took running it continuous running 14
of these arms continuously for months
performing 800,000 practice graphs and
collecting 2.8 million images and so
after all of that you basically store
images like this pair and then you
record did I grasp something or not and
then you can create a gradient where
you're like okay these are pictures
where I'm unlikely to grasp these are
pictures where I'm more likely to grasp
and do the same kind of regression
operation that we've done at all the
previous examples and note like so the
system after all this training it fails
twenty percent of time and when it does
succeed you can't tell it what to grasp
like it's just gonna try and grab
something and sometimes it'll grab two
things and when it succeeds of grasping
something it succeeds in a way I
wouldn't characterize as success like it
doesn't have a good plan about how to
grab this object it happens to work in
this particular case but if you change
the gripper or even the color of the bin
I'm not convinced it would still work
especially if you change the color of
the bin I think the color of the bin
would cause it to have a catastrophic
failure so so what can people earning do
what is a good at it's it's it's great
if you have a lot of data and you have a
lot of computers you can make really
accurate and narrow predictions and it's
basically doing fancy regression and you
know if I'm the CEO of Google or
Facebook or something
that's a really great thing in fact that
may be the best thing ever because what
I have are a lot of computers and a lot
of data and what I want are really
narrow predictions about what ad to show
someone what person's face might be in a
photo and so deep learning is terrific
and that's why they invest so much money
in it
and it has some interesting implications
so just this kind of as narrow as it is
this kind of pattern matching actually I
think is is pretty powerful and
transformative so I'm not a policy wonk
and not an economist and so I wanted to
disclaim all the things I'm about to say
as someone who's not that much more
informed about this than you are but
I'll share with you the stuff I've and
this is also you know aggregating from
many other sources that I've read about
this topic and so for further reading
all offer some recommendations but um I
think there's three main classes that I
I consider any way I want to think about
implications of this kind of narrow AI
economic social and policy economic
implications so my favorite lens on what
these kinds of narrow AI systems is is
going to do is is as a decrease in the
price of prediction because if you view
these systems as just lowering the price
of prediction then you can use all of
the standard economic tools to reason
about what kind of effects its gonna
have an economy so you can say well the
you know decrease in the price of rubber
you're gonna see use going up and you're
gonna see the value of the complements
going up because we're people were using
it so more people need the complements
and this is there's a book that just
came out recently called prediction
machines that I would recommend anyone
who wants to go deeper into what are the
economic implications of you know
standard modern AI deep learning so and
then when you say use increases like you
can use these kinds of systems
everywhere to predict whether something
is spam or not you know predict what I'm
saying when I talk to Siri predict who
I'm likely to vote for predict what you
might want to show me if you want to
change who I'm likely to vote for so as
you get down this list it sort of gets
darker and a little bit more interesting
the other implication is on the value of
complements the two complements to
systems like this are data and compute
and so companies that make computers
that are very useful for these kinds of
operations like Nvidia are going to see
a dramatic increase in the demand for
their products companies that have a lot
of data that can be utilized in these
ways like Facebook or Google are also
going to see dramatic increases in the
value they're able to capture from that
data
next certifications around society so it
might sound and it sounded to me anyway
like a really good thing that we could
have systems that would show me more
articles that I wanted to see and less
articles that I didn't want to see like
I don't want to read articles that are
boring so show me articles that are
interesting and as it turns out this is
actually kind of disastrously bad for
society because if everyone only sees
articles that they like to read and as
it turns out people like to read
articles that they agree with and that
in fact capitalize on their like worst
human instincts and prejudices then what
we get are a bunch of people who all
believe their view of the world is right
and all have the most polarized version
of their view of the world and so
there's this experiment the Wall Street
Journal did called red feed blue feed
that I would recommend all of you check
out and it just takes the most biased
articles from both sides of the spectrum
and puts them right next to each other
on the same topic and you get to see
what each side which facts each side
chooses to emphasize or invent and how
you know when you're in one of these
filter bubbles you don't know it no
one's telling you that there are other
views out there and so a lot of the
population of the world who's on these
systems just thinks that their
perspective on the truth is the truth
and so you end up with a society that's
much more divisive than it had been when
we just had nightly news and we all
watch the same four channels or
something to singulate on what would be
the truth and then the other
implications for this is once you have
these filter bubbles then you can
identify what kind of information would
be necessary to cause the bubble to
shift one or the other and that's kind
of stuff we saw in the election and
other countries other entities like what
we're seeing with Russia can then choose
to influence what's going on in people's
minds by making targeted ad buys or
targeted information campaigns at these
bubbles next certifications I think
about what I think about the narrow
edits here is about research and policy
right now we're being like catastrophic
Lee outspent by China on fundamental
research on AI robotics other fields and
I can tell you what China's strategy is
for for AI robotics and being the leader
and all of these things and I
feel like I can give you a coherent
explanation of what the United States
the strategy is which is something that
makes me uncomfortable I really feel
like our government should be thinking
very critically about how we should be
taking advantage of the new technologies
that were born here and helping them to
reach the next level more quickly and
the other thing is and this goes into
the section I'll get into about jobs
America's infrastructure is really
falling apart right now
and has been for a while and to repair
it it's not something that narrow AI
systems like this can do and so as it
turns out you a lot of people with hands
and good skills and carpentry and and
like stonework and concrete in order to
repair these things and we've kind of
lost some of our ability to do these
things last piece of policy is on
immigration so all six of the people you
probably recognize almost all six these
people so it's it's a SpaceX Google
Amazon Yahoo eBay and an apple all of
these people were either immigrants
themselves or the children of immigrants
and so I think one of the things that
has made America what it is is our
attitude towards welcoming brilliant
people from elsewhere and integrating
them and by adopting a different stance
than that I think that we're killing the
Golden Goose yeah since you're going to
leave policy before you leave policy
yeah your previous point is really
saying that we the US needs an
industrial policy and it has been the
position of the United States government
since the end of the Second World War
that having a Industrial Policy is
something that we'll never do
yeah so I'm not advocating for
industrial policy specifically and you
sound very very informed much more
informed than high office so do you
think of the NIS as industrial policy or
as basic science research because I'm
not advocating for more that oh just go
back and listen to your words about what
you said we need to do yeah
funding for fundamental research in AI
and robotics previously were a little
bit different okay well I retract my
previous words and replace them with I
want funding and fundamental research in
AI robotics
we had an interesting wouldn't he pick
on the University of Southern California
Chancellor of the University of Southern
California said the United States
government should spend more money to
help us compete with China today I yeah
he neglected to say that all of the
money that is spent and you want to see
yeah he's effectively spent educating
Chinese nationals to take their AI back
to China
so it's spending money at USC yeah did
not actually a call Perceval it did
actually help in with his bowl but just
fundraising pretty gutsy right no for
whatever but that is yeah so it's a
little weird to say we're going to do
this to to compete with somebody
well you're not gonna give everything
you've made to them yeah but I think
you're talking about a specific
instantiation of how the grants are
dispersed and like to whom receive them
and I think there can be a little bit
more granularity on that to go thing the
devil video picture pictures up there
the answers changed remarkably oh we
have a long history of you know spending
a trillion dollars and the result was
five signs saying this project funded by
yeah exactly and I think this is there's
no substitute for like thoughtful
allocations of capital and for carefully
designed programs and for all the things
that are acquired but we can't use the
money we don't spend to make advances
when we need to go backwards and
actually fix the mechanisms by which
grants are distributed in like all these
things yeah there's lots of bugs in
system to fix this topic is about the
top of the funnel and
and you know the middle on the bottom of
the funnel you know there's a hole there
talk about that maybe I mean I know
point I think is a harder line stance
than I think could possibly be justified
because even if 80% of the money is lost
by like it just sent directly overseas
or something and 20% of it fund projects
like ARPANET then we end up with
something that could be revolutionary so
I don't I don't know that you can flush
all of it so would you advocate excusing
up figuring out which agency to use up
in one way or another and juicing up an
agency or would you say we need an
overall overarching strategy which has a
budget I mean I'm going to refer back to
my my disclaimer slide and say what I'd
advocate for is that someone who's very
smart and has spent a lot of time
studying these kinds of policies and
programs be put in charge of getting us
a good one and measuring how successful
it is or is not in making adjustments to
it so that it is successful I think that
would be an interesting stuff I love
that disclaimers for things to be good
yeah the US would become an agrarian
nation yeah I'm not asking for any the
money I mean I I think this is this is
also the kind of thing where I think
there's a false narrative in the press
about how it's like US versus China on
this were like I think the discoveries
that are made on the path towards
creating better AI or discoveries that
are gonna be broadly beneficial and not
selectively beneficial yeah and I don't
want to hitch my wagon to anyone who's
advocated for you know somebody else
wants funding for improved RF technology
somebody else got some butter yeah for
something else yeah so you have all of
these these things that you kick that's
where you end up having have an
industrial policy job you have to say
well what is it that we want to achieve
and then you have to back back into it
yeah exactly we that would that would be
a part of the process that we need to
occur yeah haha okay great so and and
and and it sounds like lots of people
here in this room have strong opinions
about this and it would be fun to have a
fog conversation after the talk okay so
next part of this is kind of talking
about where we go from here
obviously these deep loading systems are
effective at a certain range of things
but to get to the next level as you
mentioned the being of this talk I don't
think we can rely exclusively on big
data pattern-matching old brain kinds of
systems and I think that we can draw
some inspiration for what happened and
evolution in order to figure out where
exactly we look for the next generation
of these systems I'll give some examples
from the animal kingdom
so whales in captivity are trained to
pick up trash in their tanks and trade
them with the trainer for fish and one
day a seagull died and fell into the
tank and instead of getting one fish as
reward the animal got to because it was
like a big object or something and you
imagine a frog would just like eat both
rewards and now would be that the whale
did not the whale saved the second fish
and then used it as bait to catch
additional seagulls which had then
drowned and trained with a trainer for
even more fish create a stockpile of
fish at the bottom its tank and then it
used those fish to teach the other
whales in the tank how to participate in
the seagull for fish economy the next
favorite example so there's a gorilla in
captivity named Coco that this is not
Coco but I'm not allowed to use footage
that I don't copyright to so this is
just a gorilla so Coco was raisin kept
in view her favorite thing to do is
watch a TV program called Mister Rogers
neighborhood which many of you probably
saw mr. Rogers found that Coco was a fan
of his show so she went to visit him at
the zoo and if you recall mr. Rogers
show he starts it by like welcoming the
children to his house he takes off his
shoes and he teaches them the lust of
the day
the first thing KOCO wanted to do with
mr. Rogers when he met him when she met
him was to help him take off his shoes
because that's how he always started a
show last example of these kind of new
brain behaviors this is an 18 month old
human being put in a new environment
it's never been in before looking at
objects it's never seen before watching
a human it's never met before do an
action it's never seen a human do before
and it's given no instructions
[Laughter]
so why is it that humans are able to do
and other mammals are able to do these
amazing feats of very low training data
very high generalization reasoning and
the answer is you know we have a
radically different circuit in our heads
than our our reptile friends or insect
friends we still have the old brain it's
down there controls our heart rate our
breathing our immune system all kinds of
important things but then on top of it
there's this completely different
circuit called the neocortex if you cut
it off the brain and you lay it flat
it's the size shape and thickness of a
dinner napkin and different parts of it
correspond different functions like
there's a part for hearing a part for
seeing part for language part for motor
actions part for spatial reasoning but
it's all the same roughly the same
replicated circuit so if you take a
tissue sample from each of those regions
and give them to a trained
neuroscientist they'll have a hard time
telling which is from which region and
that's also even true across mammals so
if you give a neocortical sample from a
whale of rhinoceros a human and a mouse
all of those neocortex's have remarkably
similar wiring patterns and they can
even do these really cool experiments
where they they take a ferret and they
sever the optic nerve and instead of
allowing it to grow into the part of the
neocortex it normally processes vision
they force it to grow into the part that
normally processes is hearing and the
ferret can see so it's a it's a
replicated circuit that's performing the
same kind of mathematical operation and
it actually has the inverse
characteristics of deep learning so
mammalian brains take incredibly little
training data in order to learn new
concepts new ideas they generalize
really well to new environments and
circumstances and most importantly they
learn this causal model the world that
lets us ask what if and why reason
backwards from effects their causes and
simulate forward in time and that is a
really important thing to have if you're
in a body and you want to solve problems
with your body because we don't get
infinite training data to be in this
particular room
manipulating these particular objects
chances are you just get one chance at
it and so you need a system that's very
very fast at learning to be in new
environments and reusing knowledge it
already has that's the kindest and so we
work at it like curious in contrasts the
kind of deep learning architectures
where you just have a stimulus a black
box and response we work on systems that
try and build causal relationships in
the world build a causal understanding
so we can do forwards and backwards
reasoning and I'll give you some
examples of that and we focus on these
kinds of causal models from a business
perspective anyway because there's this
really weird paradox that we all live in
where the parts that go in robots like
motors and plastics and metal and
electricity and processors sensors are
all really cheap and nobody owns any you
know if you go into a factory a hundred
years ago and a factory now like
basically nothing changes it's like you
get color color is what changes and we
have people doing jobs that robots have
been physically capable of doing you
know for over a decade and the reason we
have that is because we don't have an
intelligence layer that you can use to
control the robot so this is a video of
basically Rosie the robot from the
Jetsons and the trick of this video it's
a video from 11 years ago the trick of
this video is the robots being
controlled by a human so as long as you
have a human brain you can do almost
anything you want with a robot if I just
gave you a normal robot gripper and had
you live your everyday life with it I
think you could do 90% of the things
that you do every day and so
functionally we're already living in the
Jetsons society we're just missing the
advances in AI necessary to make robots
useful and ubiquitous and that's what
we're building it vicariously that's
what a lot of our research leads into
it's sort of like until inside robots
I'll just get through this part so when
we talk about how you know how do we
approach the problem of working on AI
specifically we're gonna have for
embodiment there's a very famous
computer science theorem called the no
free lunch theorem which basically they
prove that every algorithm only gets
power by making assumptions so like mp3
was good at compressing songs because it
assumes that you're a human and you're
listening to music and so it can throw
away any data that's too high frequency
or too low
you can see that's in inaudible for you
to hear it can also assume that the left
ear on the right ear are hearing roughly
the same song so you just store one of
the two ears and then you know the diff
for the right ear so you make all these
assumptions and it gets good at doing
what it's designed to do like
compressing songs and the strength of
deep learning strength of the AI that
most people use today
is that it doesn't make any assumptions
you could use the same architecture to
recognize images to play go to play
Atari to regulate you know temperature
sensor is in a data center you do
anything with it
and that's both its strength and its
weakness and so to get to systems that
are more like our brains more like the
mammalian brain if you make stronger
assumptions and in our view those
assumptions come from physics so and I
think of them it's sort of like
properties of the universe so like
spatial regularity is a good one when
you look at my face the pixels that make
up my face aren't teleporting at random
all over your visual field they stay
together and when I move my head from
side to side my eyes nose and mouth move
with my head and when you move your head
like this the room transforms itself in
the same way every time and so there's
all these statistical regularities or
the fact that objects exist and objects
tend to have attributes that persist
over time like this table is still wood
and all these things are things we can
take advantage of when we look at how do
we create models that match the
properties of the systems that we're
looking to exploit and this is the kind
of work that we've been doing it by
curious the first thing that we did and
this is five six years ago now is we
wanted to build a vision system modeled
after mammalian neocortex that had
human-like ability to generalize to
shape recognition and so the way we
tested it was the same way humans test
each other as can you perceive like a
human we showed it captions and the
problem with with tech reading text and
reading captures occipital efore like an
old brain style AI system is that
there's like a zillion different ways
that even just one letter can vary and
so to get your old brainy AI system to
recognize all of them you need to show
it a gazillion examples whereas when you
read all these CAPTCHAs you've probably
never seen many of the styles of words
that appear on the screen but
miraculously you're able to
without any training and that's the the
kinds of properties that we were looking
to capture in our systems yeah yeah it's
true I mean so a lot of the earlier work
on how do you break CAPTCHAs tried to
exploit that kind of idea but what the
design of these kinds of systems
exploits that breaks that style of
system is that notice how in most of the
examples the letters are touching each
other and so if you have an image like
this where most letters are touching
each other or this one is even worse and
then you're all you have is that input
now you have to guess what were the
transformations that were applied in
terms of rotations scales
you know warps noise it's very difficult
to figure out where the gradient is to
climb into oh it's getting more and more
word like oh I'm getting closer and
closer to reading a letter here because
you don't know where the boundaries the
letters are because they're touching
each other so you can't pre segment the
letters all of the old attacks and
captures involved pre segmentation and
so in order to be able to solve these in
a general way you really need something
I mean maybe there's some way to do it
that I don't know about that you know a
smart person can't figure out but a lot
of people have tried because it turns
out there's a lot of money be made in
scamming banks and like stealing
people's stuff and so you kind of need a
system like ours so this is something I
think it's curious if that you want to
give a shot so we this is a you can read
the paper online this is something we
published a couple of maybe I don't know
eight months ago or something that goes
into the details of the specifics to the
kind of generator models that we focused
on about curious and the the
neuroscience inspiration for them and
how
they relate to some the other work I'm
not gonna go into too much depth on that
today we also tested on reading street
signs against the kind of old brain deep
learning methods so this is a case where
by having stronger bias about what is a
mammalian brain doing we're able to
build systems that outperform old brain
systems and use a lot less training data
and for a pictorial representation on
the left is like the Google training
dataset which is 8 million images on the
right is the vicarious training set
which if you're having trouble seeing
it's because it's in the dot of the eye
and then with that lets us do is than we
when you're in a new environment and you
see a bunch of random objects on a table
you can look at them once and then in
our system get 50 degrees of 3d rotation
invariance and you can put those objects
in industrial environments where robots
need to manipulate them and the robots
can then cope with those environments
and changes in lighting and all kinds of
things that are difficult for
conventional AI systems we can also
apply it to control so this is the the
the deep mines deep reinforcement
learning system called AC 3 or a 3 C
actor critic and us a were arson on the
left that we have a paper and ICML that
you can download and read about how this
works exactly it's a little bit too
complex to explain and just this talk
but we can do things like if you make
the image brighter obviously we can keep
right on playing you can do things like
move the pedal up so this is analogous
to a calibration air and a robot as it
turns out robots oftentimes will move
their arm to an intended end effector
state and they'll be off by a little bit
and so you need to be able to compensate
for for noise and your motors and joints
whereas if you're if you're working with
a deep learning based system it's going
to have a lot of trouble generalizing to
these kinds of variations or this one's
sort of interesting so this is what
happens to deep mind system at the end
of the game and because when you go back
and think of that that giant array of
fifty million training frames was
trained on very few of those frames are
frames where there's just one brick left
most of them are frames where those lots
of bricks left and so now it's in it's
in a state where it doesn't have a lot
of training data anymore and I I'm bet
you or you know it's there probably only
zero or one games where it happened to
have just this brick left and so you see
it's missing the ball a whole lot and
then when it does hit the ball it
doesn't hit it with any intentionality
like it has no plan for how does it hit
that last brick if I let this video play
we have to wait another 15 minutes
before clear the board and because it's
just responding in a stimulus response
way it's not being able to make these
long-term plans it's not able to aim to
achieve a goal which when you're in a
body is a really important feature and
when you have a model of causality and
you can say okay this is the brick I
want to hit you can reason backwards to
where your hand needs to be in order to
hit the hit the ball in the direction
that's gonna enable you to clear the
board it also enables you to cope with
obstacles like yeah but they didn't have
enough training set that covered oh yeah
that they could have but I I think the
the then the further case comes in in
reality you can't synthesize all the end
games because there's an infinite number
of positions that objects can be on
there's an infinite variety of objects
that you may encounter or obstacles that
may occur during the course of you know
you're being in a body and needing to
interact with the door is broken or
loose or whatever there's a million
things you know not for this case but I
think the the aim of deep mind is not to
play Atari games it's to build systems
that start to capture more intelligent
behaviors in the way you and I describe
intelligence and so this is another one
of those examples where how many
different configurations of walls can
you come up with and eventually we
explode the training say because it's
it's 50 million frames just to train the
no wall version and then you start
adding walls every to position you start
changing the size and shape of the board
the height of the paddle and now we're
in a combinatorial explosion yeah and
the problem in a constraint if you
reduce the degrees of freedom but
unfortunately the real world has lots of
degrees of freedom an unfortunate thing
yes and you know and this isn't like
ours where you have a model of causality
you can then you know immediately say oh
there's a wall there so I just need to
aim to the left in order to continue get
reward so it's it's it's
by watching the game played it watches
what happened so it's looking for causal
relationships and notices that when the
ball or when this entity makes contact
with entities that are gray it reverses
direction so it's a thing it's we don't
give it any knowledge of physics at all
it's just learning causality
relationships and then from that I
learned schemas that it can then use to
pick the future of reason backwards
right on the slavish pattern-recognition
rather than image filtering that says
light things are walls for example or
things with certain colors or walls and
not mapping this to greyscale so that oh
so he doesn't know he doesn't know that
great things are walls it knows it all
noses there's a whole bunch of entities
in the world and that's that that's the
knowledge it starts with and we can even
eyes none of us thought I had but I
didn't include in this particular talk
where we actually do change the colors
randomly that's something we could come
to we didn't actually implement that and
that's something we could add later and
I think humans actually do write what
you have it you have a prior that says
oh it looks at we called it an
affordance right you have an affordance
for oh it looks like a button it's
probably a button it looks like a wall
it's probably well this is another
example where you get to that comment
Oriole explosion of okay well what if we
make the walls move and change their
positions velocities and this one really
puts pressure on how well can you
actually plan because you have to in
order to get any points at all you
really have to know where everything's
going and aim very exposed and give you
a visualization of what our systems
actually doing so the screen is gonna
turn white while the screen is white the
game is paused and it's just unrolling
all possible futures and so you can see
it's it's not the learn dynamics that
it's come up with by observing this game
and then it picks the where it gets
reward which is right down the middle
and then it models again so it doesn't
move here at all because it is a need to
so
we can also apply that same codebase to
you know solving complicated puzzle
games like this where it's it's not
about reaction it's about reasoning
through a long series long causal chain
in order to arrive at a destination
where if you make missteps along the way
you can get into an unsolvable state
does it have every possible does it
explore every possible no it's so this
is one I can send you the paper if you
like that kind of goes into all the
details about it so what's it's set up
as a probably graphical model and we do
belief propagation in it and anyway
let's get on to the the Rope so the
rhotic stuff this is um so this year
we've been putting all of these systems
together inside actual robot bodies and
having them do the kinds of tasks that
children do and adults eventually do to
get to this future where robots are
increasingly common when we talk about
implications of like what happens you
know in the next iteration of AI the
kinds of stuff that we're building it
vicarious and that other people are
building elsewhere at other institutions
I think that you get a pretty clear
picture of where we're going with just
one chart this is the index price of
labor versus the index price of a robot
since 1990 and the robot side is
actually this chart was made a little
bit prematurely because the robot side
has dropped off precipitously in the
last two years actually and we've just
reached the point where a small robot is
less expensive than the annual salary of
a Chinese factory worker and so robots
are getting very affordable we're in
this in the middle of the sort of
perfect storm of all these different
technologies becoming available like
your iPhone X comes with an RGB D camera
in it that's a very power efficient and
pretty accurate and fast and that's
another great tool to have in your
button in your toolbox when you're when
you're building something that needs to
see the world and have depth perception
so and this I've already sort of
answered this question but if if like if
labor is getting incredibly expensive
and robots are incredibly affordable why
doesn't everyone use them not to pick
fun of one of my investors but
traditional automation is very rigid
like to program a robot to do something
today you give it a list of
points in 3d space that it's supposed to
move it's end-effector through and if
you want to tell me how to make a
sandwich as a list of 3d coordinates to
hold my hands in it's gonna take a month
for you to you know convey to me how to
do it and then if someone like moves the
bread a little bit to the left during
the course of me making the sandwich I'm
gonna be putting peanut butter on the
table so it's a very very brittle way of
accomplishing tasks and it especially if
you want to do something inside of a car
like Elon is doing where you're you're
trying to harness wires through the
inside of a of a chasis and those wires
are bendable and so you need a
closed-loop perception perception and
visual reasoning system in order to know
where to move your hands and I think
there's actually this really interesting
parallel between robotics right now and
computers in 1950 so in 1950 if you
wanted a computer to do something for
you you basically needed a completely
bespoke system that a engineering firm
built for you that only did the one
thing that you Specht out in the RFP and
robots are the exact same situation
today if you want a robot to do
something you hire a custom engineering
firm you read an RFP you get bids and
they spend months or a year building a
system to do that for you
and I think robotics in the future is a
lot like computers in the present day
where they're just you know cheap
ubiquitous general-purpose and we don't
think about them anymore in the same way
that we don't really think about
computers anymore and I think of another
what lens I like on this is right now
compute has reached the point where it's
like electric the price of electricity
plus some epsilon and I think in the
future as these trends continue we'll
get to a world where labor is the price
of electricity plus some epsilon which
has some implications that you might be
wondering about with respect to labor
over labor markets if you ask the
internet like what's gonna happen in the
world where these types of AI systems
robot systems exist the internet will
tell you that it's the end of the world
and that we're all screwed and there
aren't any jobs anymore and I actually
think there's like a very underplayed
counter narrative that I think is worth
talking about so you when you're on the
internet you may read articles that say
stuff like this where you know we're
being afflicted with technological
unemployment where people can't get jobs
anymore anyone guess when it
was written wellmaybe undershooting a
little bit this is 1930 yeah
1930 yeah so this is not a new problem
like the problem of having machines do
stuff is not a new problem and I I think
one of the things that gives me comfort
about the coming job apocalypse is if
you look at the last 3,000 years of
human history it's it's 3000 years of
people building contraptions that take a
job that used to take five people a day
to do and turn into a job it takes one
person a couple of hours to do and
that's everything from the printing
press to the wheel to the telephone and
after 3,000 years of doing that we have
more people and we have more jobs and we
have a better standard of living than
we've ever had and so to me this
standard of proof required to believe
that this time is different is very very
high
and I think the best model we have a
mapping we have is 1900 Zagreb for
revolution where you we went from 40
percent of the u.s. working age
population work in a farm to 2 percent
and despite that enormous shift in where
labour was deployed it wasn't we have 38
percent unemployment it was you know
every decade since 1890 basically the
labor participation rate has gone up and
I think that you know another great
example is is you look at ATM machines
when ATM machines were introduced people
thought it was gonna be the end of bank
tellers no Bank was going to play bank
tellers anymore and all of those people
be out of work and in reality we have
more bank tellers now than we've ever
had what ATM machines did is they made
the unprofitable parts of banking go
away taking deposits and giving out
withdrawals and then freed up the bank
tellers spent all their time selling
very profitable things like home loans
and credit cards and so on yeah
yeah that's true so in some cases
technology disruptions do so what if I
have the chart here I do okay so this is
taxi drivers and ride-sharing so there'd
be another example so I agree in some
cases there is job destruction and like
no one operates a telephone anymore but
I would also argue that the result of
that no one goes back no one today goes
back and says man
remember the apocalypse that came when
all the telephone operators were
unemployed remember how the world fell
apart no and says that because the world
didn't fall apart like everyone got new
jobs and it was fine I there's large
communities in New Jersey depressed
because of the change it just an empty
lived in an area where agriculture has
been supported not by growing but by the
government pain not to grow and then
when government payments of the drawing
no see everybody in call centers yeah I
grew up in Lancaster Pennsylvania yeah
yeah in farm country so III I don't have
a myopic view that it's gonna be better
for everyone and and the future is full
of magic unicorns I think that there is
going to be labor displacement but the
argument I'm making here is that one
that I don't hear from the headlines
which is the headlines make the make the
cases that we're all screwed and it's
going to be like an employment wasteland
and I think the what's closer to the
truth is that there's gonna be new
different kinds of jobs some things will
be destructive other things will be
creative and the effects aren't always
predictable and so this is a classic
case in point real like okay the taxi
industry is doomed because the
ride-sharing and in reality consumption
of rides went up massively such that
perhaps there is a decline in the taxi
business but it's nowhere near the scale
that one might have predicted when you
look at a world where anyone can someone
a ride with their cell phone that isn't
connected the taxi services yeah perhaps
the one for ancient structures be
starting from zero
it's indexed right so it's talking about
growth and spend so this is what this
what this chart is showing is that the
spend so what you would expect right if
your if the argument is true that people
stop taking taxis you'd expect this line
the red line to to go to zero right and
instead it stays at about a hundred
which means that the spend on taxis
remains relatively constant in the face
of this new product where the spend goes
up twelve hundred percent or twelve
hundred points on this index scale right
you've done a great job opening up a
whole series of Pandora's box it is true
that for the technological revolutions
that have happened yeah up until about
ten or fifteen years ago
we it it wasn't consistent that new jobs
were created in the place the old jobs
were eliminated yeah but there was there
was a net increase in jobs to to take
over for the jobs that were lost
as a result of the development of
technology sure is and I think you're
absolutely right
it's unpredictable both ways yeah I
think I'm are you against this so the
wall of headlines that say it is the
apocalypse we are screwed that we can
end up losing jobs and it not be the
apocalypse but so you can take this out
but there's we don't know which way it's
gonna go
I completely or we definitely don't know
ways go and that's exactly the point I'm
trying to make so I'm trying to make it
so that the point that I hear in the
media generally speaking is we know
which way it's going to go and it's
going to be the apocalypse so that's
what I see and if you'll see too if you
just Google for like AI and jobs is it's
going to the apocalypse so I'm I'm
trying to introduce a counter-narrative
that says we don't know which way it's
gonna go and here's another path down
the road that we may end up on that you
know is is TBD but here's some examples
in the past where it has gone the other
way
yeah these machines will be used for
intelligence augmentation rather than
labor replacement right yeah and you
know maybe they'll keep us as their pets
the economic argument for how it's why
it's going gonna play and that's the
sort of the you know how the kind of
economic prosperity has been allocated
over the last forty years you've seen
Jeff greater growth in profits and Hana
lower growth in payment for labor unions
go to me with that says this defeat the
revolution in this doesn't necessarily
yeah let me just open a whole other ken
doors box here so I so I I tend to think
of this as a as a Miss misfire of the
design of corporate personhood or of a
corporate entity so I think right now
corporations are legally required to
maximize shareholder wealth and I think
this is not know in the state of
Delaware there at least now so can you
tell me where you were did you you can
say otherwise and your corporate bylaws
and your rules you could make it public
yeah and trade your sportingly you are
not obligated that's my process are you
talking about flexible purpose
corporations and B corporations or are
you talking about regular C corpse
because there is case law on Delaware
against Craigslist actually I believe
that they were sued for not taking
actions to maximize shareholder returns
and they lost so the the the headway of
are the the segue of this is that sorry
in California there's a special thing
called a social purpose corporation
which yeah
I mean I think it's a citation needed
thing can you point up a lot those
corporations are required to do that
it's possible there is such a long yeah
don't worry companies but I mean certain
companies even you know well-known
for-profit companies like Apple say look
you know you're just for the show well
yeah because apply elsewhere get out of
stock you know what we do is we build
computers and without companies if you
think about what they do there they're
found for purpose like FedEx delivers
packages yeah bills iPhones like only
financial companies are defined are
usually found it - like maximize the
share so I definitely it a citation on
that yeah sorry plenty of case why is
there a lawyer in the room has anyone
ever said it's one the US that says in
general without a special purpose
corporation with with provisions for the
contrary that by default the corporation
has to do share of responsibility to
maximize yeah the doesn't have to be in
the short term yeah right you plenty you
know people used to joke yeah and their
shareholders have done very well to to
maximize that that value over the long
term yeah right it doesn't necessarily
mean making short sigh decisions but
you're right that at some level that's
the purpose of a standard corporation so
I have a citation here what is your name
the point I was making is that I think
that your your count your your point
about how corporations generally
speaking make decisions that are better
for the shareholders and perhaps worse
for society I view the purpose of
corporations as things that exist for
the betterment of society not
necessarily for the better minutes of
the shareholders which are sub so
and like it ends when you have
corporations that exist only for the
better Michelle shareholders you end up
with them making decisions to
externalize things like like pollution
and streams or hiding the fact that
cigarettes cause lung cancer and so
these are choices that are I think there
there are pressures to do from a
shareholder perspective that are counter
to what we would think of as being
ethical and I think this fits into that
circle and this is this is why I said
I'm opening other Pandora's box which
probably I should have not no not to
walk into but yeah there it is degrees
of freedom so it doesn't really matter
what the laws are we develop a system
that it's going to force us in a
particular direction it's going to force
us in that direction the laws of change
and the behavior will change the
question is what are the vectors that
looking forces to move yeah yeah to the
pair's the countervailing vector in
Switzerland a year ago they had an
election and it was went to a general
vote the question was whether every
citizen should be guaranteed an income
and it lost like 49 to 51 percent was
really good at resource allocation mm-hm
and up until now human labor has been
scarce but if it turns out that there's
a lot of excess human labor then one
outcome is that everybody gets an income
for being formed and that you have to
pay yeah all right so I think that's a
really interesting possible future and I
also I mean the other side of it for me
is and this kind of goes into the next
slide isn't the last month talking um is
I don't in my view I don't think labor
is going to be scarce like I think
there's so much that humans can do to
make our society better than it is right
now and we don't live in Jetsons world
and we're very far from there because
it's so expensive to build things
and there's a there's a shortage like in
my previous slide seven million unfilled
welding positions the united states line
this is a random subset of jobs with
like there's a lot of unfilled jobs and
that's suddenly unfilled welding
positions without large-scale
infrastructure projects to like fix
parts of our nation's infrastructure
that are are in decline is everything
bullying new stuff and so i think there
is a lot of opportunities for labor to
be done and there are areas where it's
gonna be really hard to have a robot
it is general-purpose enough to be able
to do the motor actions required to
navigate construction sites and perform
those tasks so i think there are lots of
opportunities for labor so yes you may
be right but the other side would argue
that if i can 3d print it what is it man
yeah so new technologies may emerge and
all kinds interesting stuff can happen
so i I guess the and this comes back to
so what what does this mean what
opportunities might this create what
risks are there we cover some of the
risk in my view there's so many
different enabling technologies that
come together in a world where not not
only is prediction cheap in the big data
internet since the word but labor gets
cheaper because the hardware in the
software and the sensor isn't the chips
necessary to make labor cheap get more
abundant and so I think that that's the
the final takeaway I would say is like
what is where's a where is there a
rising tide in this particular area I
would say there izing tide is around the
different enabling technologies that
come together to make autonomy more
affordable more Universal and and to
think critically about if you're looking
at this from a business or a cylon
engineering perspective where we're
using labor now where would we use labor
if it were dramatically less expensive
and how would that change the way this
aspect of business respects society
tends to function so that's all the
thoughts I for you today happy to take
questions thanks for attention
yeah
thank you for talkin the answers a
question with your basic premise of
reptilian brain or brain brain
the fact is mammalian brain a toddler
for example to be able to open a door
the toddler has had to have been exposed
to many many millions of images it's
trend that's common in old mammals and
learning is essential absolutely
well this is absolutely not true with
insects for example it washed out of the
cocoon the minute gets out of the cocoon
is able to hunt for prey late sag you
know their sting the prey without no
learning whatsoever yeah so you see some
of that too like horses when they're
born can immediately walk which is
something that takes humans years to to
be able to develop or maybe it depends
on how the child comes along but maybe
six months so yeah there's definitely a
mix of learned behaviors in training
data is really important part of it it
from the calculations I've done anyway
if you make some reasonable assumptions
about you know the the kid is colorblind
and happens to only have monocular
vision and it's got some deficiencies so
the visions a little blurry so if you
make some assumptions like that and
calculate the amount of training data
that a three-year-old gets during that
period it's in the order of terabytes or
maybe tens of terabytes so it's not an
unfathomably large amount of training
data for today's computers to consume is
very difficult to make these things
because there's a process of biological
process called myelination the pestis
the nervous system of a usual human
child does not work right until the
nerves are coated with fat it's called
myelination it doesn't work so it
doesn't matter how many times you've
been closed to whatever picture or
whatever if that part of your nervous
system is not functioning at be able to
capture that information that doesn't
matter yeah and until that happens and
when that happens typically blue with
human children it doesn't take very many
repetitions and maybe none at all so
it's very complicated to try to do it
that way yeah I guess the calculations
from for my perspectives even assuming
that we we've had myelination happen at
birth even assuming that it's only on
the order of terabytes or tens of
terabytes a day which is not a ton of up
to 10 or markedly
smarter so I should have actually
included a section on birds this is
sometimes people bring this up sometimes
they don't but birds have a very very
cortex they basically have an analogous
cortex like structure in their brains
that does the same functions as our
cortex and it's a very similar structure
so I would say that that the
computations that the birds are doing
the computers we're doing are if they're
not the same computation they're very
very close the the cephalopod case I
have no idea how an oculus works
octopuses i think are fascinating i wish
i know until recently they were really
listened to be incapable of smart and
social behavior nothing a lot has to do
with our inability to observe and have
noticed
intelligent behavior in the lower
animals and so i would be careful to
draw conclusions on the you know
role of the cortex into making a machine
able to so problem generalize and
because fish for example you know my
experience has shown you know amazing
Ashland actually we don't know we don't
know very much and it might be just that
we just don't know that interesting we
haven't observed intentions because
we're not able to actually perhaps we
don't even know what to look for
yeah detective I would love to so I
would love if you could maybe give me
some some more concrete after the talk
give me some more concrete examples of
this stuff because I it's it's I think
it's really incredibly fascinating and
it's something I want to know more about
because I think there's some lessons we
could draw from there to the examples
that I have in my talk and there's some
there lots of others we can come up with
but it's basically trying to show that
intelligent looking behaviors are
actually simple heuristics behind the
scenes and I agree it's incredibly
difficult unless you do the kinds of
experiments that are the ones that I
talked about where you like have the
iPhone in front of the Frog or you have
the the the the the tape recorder inside
of the wolf taxidermy it's hard to
reveal is the animal smart or is it just
following a simple pattern and it's a
really interesting area of research and
one that I wish I knew I wish I had even
more examples from so let's talk about
that after this yeah I mean we this I
would say that's a whole separate thing
the behaviors that I think are most
interesting for this era are this coming
era of AI like a are getting in sort of
the era after this one the era I'm
talking about is the ones we're like the
robots can like make a sandwich in a
kitchen
you know it's an arbitrary kitchen and
so they like know you know how to take
the forks out and like move the peanut
butter around and stuff and that's those
are tasks where you don't need a
justification you don't need conceptual
knowledge and the kinds of explanations
people give that are sort of ego
defending and like it's you know there's
a whole layer of nuance there that is
even far beyond the kinds of stuff that
I'm talking about but I mean hopefully
someday the machines will give us
long-winded explanations of why they did
something
I'm still hung up on a slide about five
slides back showing the normalized
expenditure on vaccines versus rideshare
services can you back up yeah well let's
see if we can figure it out together
the thing that I'm hopeful that it says
and maybe doesn't say this but the thing
I'm hopeful it says is that after the
introduction of uber spend on taxis
wasn't significantly affected the fact
that that's normalized to 7 2015 means
nothing what if you had normalized that
with 100 as
mid-2016 or as January 2017 you would
have had along zero that this started
rising I mean if I normalize it here you
know yeah I wish they were both in
dollars and that's something I have to
do but I guess that the question I'm
asking is does it matter so like if we
normalize here or like here chart is
showing is it not so like this is saying
that it's about you know here's 100 and
it's still about a hundred at both sides
so does it matter where we started the
normalization like if there was a ten
fold the clients and it spend on taxis
this black line would be heading towards
the mob saying the dollar spent on the
Green Line is still less than the
dollars spent on the taxi line the
incursion of the right search service
wouldn't be significant enough to cause
movement change
since the time scale showed
inappropriately so yeah we have a data
point from this case lawyer
Cohen Trump's fixer so which would
suggest that this is wrong in some way
you know it suggests that the future
value of the taxi shields the future
value of the taxi in your city has
fallen based on what people expect yeah
they also could be wrong yeah right but
based on five suicides of taxi NSW is
moose s is five more or less than the
average like how does this compare the
dentist suicides in New York City okay
but this is New South Wales correct in
Australia and yeah is it yeah million so
New South Wales is a very particular
environment it has a very low population
density and it has a particular
employment pattern yeah in a particular
economic space which is radically
different from New York City I mean you
could not find to differ
to more dissimilar places and something
else in Sydney New South Wales is the
state in which Melbourne is no Sydney is
a minister well so I think what I'm
hearing is I should probably take this
slide out of my nose it's not so this
slide is not particularly important to
the points to make overall cuz then you
can tell the truth because
you